well this is embarrassing so these come
out much later than when the early ones
air cuz we kind of shoot them
back-to-back but so there's probably
about five of these V logs where we say
you know man is some ving dreams of
amazing and he's not nearly as good as
Tony J oh my god
I'm pretty good I don't remember who did
it but I'm pretty sure the ving rhames
thing was me it was I get that I know AJ
was definitely that was that was you and
I think I just blindly agreed like yeah
because I haven't seen it it sounds just
like obviously I've looked it up and it
it doesn't that much but I needed I
haven't seen the that spider-man show
since it aired like in the mid night now
it's just saw the daredevil movie so
what's your excuse for that
well my excuses I'm just terrible with
the actors and names no add the funniest
thing I do
okay okay cuz like I give names wrong
all the time you know sometimes he does
too when you do it with a black person
it makes it like 10 times when people
when people said that cuz I hadn't seen
hey you're the one who added suit so I
don't look at the footage like I might
have caught it had I seen it again but
when I saw it in the comments I'm like
wait no I couldn't have him oh no the
place for me was when I was looking up
to make sure Tony J cuz I lost my man
she doesn't make sure you know what
wasn't confused with another and I typed
in Tony J kingpin and all they came up
with all the comments saying Doug Walker
thought Tony was like you wanna make one
thing clear because I'm sure people
would be like dude that's racist I've
made a list of my of actors I normally
confuse you are really diehard approving
you were never a said exactly so but not
like some of the merge with Jim Utley
kind of funny because I saw your
Facebook
yeah I did post some of these on
Facebook and some like Gary Busey and
Nick Nolte somebody said that needs to
be a sitcom now other ones I confuse
Bill Pullman and Bill Paxton
everyone gets yeah they don't look alike
to be I just don't we saw the names yeah
Kevin James and Jon Favreau
I've confused I've confused Ryan
Reynolds and Ryan Gosling
so I'm body yeah okay no I I don't know
how I do this but I've done it before
leelee sobieski and Scarlett Johansson I
have control no no that no I know I know
you were racist against white women
right now yeah that's fucked up
I see I do not discriminate I just fuck
it up with everybody well with me
everyone knows my bad memory soon Vin
Diesel Dwayne Johnson I've done though
yeah I've done it I early on I've done
it yeah back at the man with man parts
you shamed of yours I have a shame see
this is a confusing Harrison form with
Tommy Lee Jones he knows a confession
this is a confession uh let's see
oh the biggest one that I I still did
this Nathan Fillion and Jeremy Renner I
confuse all the time I am just so
fascinating how much you want to make
yourself look bad right now I'm really
are you made of lips because if it
happens again maybe it'll be on the list
you know what just go to that list this
is what I bet these are the ones I
listed okay so it happens again and most
importantly and last but not least I
have confused Hayden Christensen with an
inanimate carbon rod that happens all
the time so apology stating Christensen
but I can the Star Wars movies like it
just looks like a rod is fighting with a
rod or net sections episode with the
inanimate carbon rod I keep thinking
that same Christensen when they're all
like all hail the rod and he's on the
cover of Time magazine that happens all
the time so any shit what's that you're
talking about the episode Jesus Christ
come on but we've got one more thing and
it's not a fuckup but somebody pointed
this out and I do think it's amazing
apparently that fight at the end of
episode two they're claiming they did it
in one shot I don't know if I buy it
possible but it's highly unlikely yeah
Robot Chicken
okay I'll give them the benefit of the
doubt if they claim it I'm not gonna
call them liars I mean there's some
things I really didn't believe in though
I know though do call them liars because
then people forget about what I said
but Michael Clarke Duncan in pink know
there's stuff like I really didn't think
Sequoia Weaver made that shot at Alien
Resurrection was like no no she really
did night I still sort of squit my eyes
a little bit but like every fucking
person the world kind of verifies it so
it's like okay there's like no evidence
proving not but there's more but it's
proving so so so what will give the
benefit of the doubt I mean impressive I
mean you know if it's not it's still
impressive I think that's the complete
list of fuck-ups or things we need to
talk about from previous episodes so any
episode I let's talk about it uh it's
great to see daredevil finally go up
against ving rhames
we've been waiting for this for a long
time
so no I but I really it is first of all
great start you know what no you fucking
start I'm just gonna say it would be
awesome if you went up against not
kingpin just been great ving rhames is
his own character but no it's cool to
see him go up against I keep it but how
great starting off cuz you think the
only fight you're gonna guess is pretty
cool fight with this ninja guy who you
then find out how you say his name again
no boo no boo yeah it is no boo which
was a good Nabil but would know which I
mean after I found out then we see him
die evil ways fucking of I also still
got a few breaths nah still tries to
fight them I'm like I really wish they'd
get worried about this guy I kind of
feel bad boy oh he's just a complaining
I know you said it was supposed to be
like one of the hand ninja outfits so my
guess is we're gonna see the hand at
least again yeah um but yeah it was one
of those things where I was just like oh
I kind of I feel bad for this guy's like
you know I show you great honor I you
know at least you can do it showed me to
say I was like this guy suddenly got
really cool I first said they were there
to be on fucking fire and yeah first
he's kind of like the rushes like you
weiter but it's like holy shit this guy
really kicked ass and now he's dead I
feel solid now we know that know who was
completely correct he thought he was
getting screwed over somehow my fist
game is pretty much it's like yeah he
was becoming the problem so thanks for
setting him on fire I do feel more
Balaam a guy with no I do I feel very
bad what she would yah-hoo hate the
elderly I'm like Murdock lured out of
hiding
I do love their legs like I didn't know
if it extended to the elderly he's like
no passing like he covers that's the
thing about fisk e keeps like trying to
distance himself I took no joy in her
passing like he didn't say
death or killing like because that would
imply that he's he's becoming so much
he's just becoming more and more
enjoyable as their villain you know it
just with that that direction he's
decided to take it or the tractor I
should both I guess
and it's just so much fun to see him
talk in that way and just how he's gonna
react to things I love seeing how he's
gonna react to stuff and man that
wonderful scene when goes to the art
gallery which is already giving you
chills cuz it's like if the kingpin
doesn't have something planned like that
play staked out surely she does because
she even that's a fucking criminal
mastermind too and yeah as soon as you
say why don't you ask him yourself B you
just see him come in it's like yeah man
you just feel the intimidation Mel when
they're just looking at each other
talking you just see the size of him
compared to your hero I mean you know
he's big well we see your hero you know
looking up at him you know I mean it's
just it's a very intimidating scene and
then when they finally meets at the end
I'm like oh yeah I've been waiting for
this I've been waiting and it's song
we're gonna say yeah I just I've always
wanted one of the one of the cool scenes
in the daredevil movie was when ving
rhames goes up against Matt Damon it was
just amazing so when they see them fight
it's like that was really cool and I've
always wanted to see a widget
kingpin I mean Michael Clarke don't get
it it's Michael Clarke Duncan he's
seeing him go off again he's saying it
this guy direct all comments to him see
him go up against
you know daredevil is cool but it's even
cooler to see him go up against like a
real you know I want to see like well I
think - really well thought out - and
it's some internet movie the movie
daredevil never did was there was just
no connection between the two Michael
Clarke Duncan's performance is amazing
but the writing doesn't vacuum up
because there's the killing of the
father but that's I mean that's a big
deal go get me wrong no somehow like but
you don't feel a connection though even
with that like I had this issue where I
just didn't feel like these two were
like like a hero and a villain like
destined to battle like this one I think
sets it up much better well there's much
more atmosphere and environment to it
when you know what they say in the movie
is much more you know we only deal with
those they're innocent nobody's innocent
you know I want to bring you on no we're
not good I mean it's straightforward why
they don't like any but you know why
they don't like each other but you don't
quite feel it like you do here cuz it
creates that atmosphere creates that
dread and it's established these
characters so well you want to see these
two go up against each other cuz you
know it would be such a good fight that
these characters are just larger than
life you feel the animosity between the
two and I don't know who's to blame I
felt I I think it's just the writing
like cuz Michael Clarke Duncan I thought
the performance was fine maybe I wasn't
getting add to it it's not yeah I just
felt like there wasn't any really
animosity between the two no just felt
like a staged fight well here we have
again we have time in this and they've
had yeah the phone calls they had you
know eating each other on the TV and
stuff like that I mean you it it's been
building up we're in one of even the
little scenes like where he Fisk walks
in and he just squeezes like the cane
like her yeah you just feel that rage
and at the end that fight
I love Fisk's fighting style because he
is very guerilla yeah he loses it and he
just smells like a gorilla you beat me
to it I was gonna say it's like a
gorilla girl like just pounding
the guy and then like again the little
touches like a little how the newspaper
covered in Murdock's blood sticks to his
back like two big wound I can just kind
of feel them like yeah well you get the
fight with the hand their idea it's like
Harry Thai that's you know something
slice it like ooh I don't know how he
survives cuz like maybe the chemicals
gave them super strength but yeah that's
all I'll take you to like you know I'm
like this no it doesn't get like jumps
up the other detail like his weight
jumps in the water would have been easy
to show jump in the water but all of
that blood yeah just you know in the
water like you expect jaws to jump out
of there and the one thing I mean I
really just said I just shot it oh come
on is when Fisk has beaten down he's
fucking right there and it's just like
whistling twist his neck do whatever but
first first time I saw it I thought the
same thing I'm like Wesley I'm like what
no you do it
well what I love too is that you know
you were saying like you know some jokes
he had to accept and I accept that but I
accept you know you could have had he
holds him up he's about to deliver the
finishing blow and then maybe like you
know daredevil like you know whatever
moves out of the way he hits the wall if
he falls to the ground and says he jumps
out the window you do not fucking let
the kingpin just be like you know Wesley
I mean this is a fucking criminal
mastermind how could he be the new Tom
escape lady cow said I should control my
blood pressure Wesley you should yeah I
I don't get that um so yeah but aside
from that uh still really really good
good episode for foggy too like the
scenes where he was reacting as he feels
like he failed the old woman well yeah
woman and when they're getting drunk
doing the Irish wake that was really
good too
do you think I went on a touch too long
what do you think with them when they're
at the bar and everything they're just
it's still crying they're still going
I'm like okay you had me at the seeing
the body but something about still see
it was I thought it was a hit money you
know I think you need to show how much
it affects them particularly versus
Murdoch's reaction because he for the
most part yeah he plays it completely
straight like now his way of dealing
with it is to go kick some ass but I
mean his initial reaction like they're
like it's her and he's just just
completely still while he's doing you
know that's where that happened sorry
was I forgot about that it was about
honesty was that yeah it was there so he
has that but it's it's a buried rage
where as foggy and Karen where their
emotions on their sleeves know you know
what it is yeah I think that's a things
the fact that you see the reaction from
when they see the body and it's a really
good I mean both of my me both uh and I
think it's so much and it's so heavy man
he's gonna get misty-eyed I'm like oh
I'm not the old lady but but to see it
then sort of come back again with the
drinking and it looking very similar
that's kind of like you know oh okay I
mean there's I understand like you know
we got to do something you need that
scene where it's like you don't pay back
and stuff but something about so you
know like just that the drinking waste
like you know a Irish wake whatever like
that would have been fine but it's like
just tell me what kind of a world
killing it gets drunker I don't know a
different sad face they can do or
something I don't know it's really did
thank you I know we'll have an
interesting conversation about the next
episode because I have similar thoughts
about the next episode more than or
maybe the one after we'll see which
one's next
well know what the last thing I'll say
is okay so Murdoch comes home foggy
comes in finally realizes his Murdoch
but how does he find out he he lifts the
mast up to here and he's like Murdoch
and it's like yeah I could tell by
looking at his eyes you never see his
eyes what would that reveal he's he's
his best friend he's seen him without
the glass yeah but no how often and how
often with his eyes closed and stuff
it's like if you took out the whole
thing you'll be like oh okay or even if
he saw this shit it's we don't make
if you could tell the difference like
you know with the eyes closed and
nothing else but keeps you be able to
tell with the chin just the chin I they
did a study cuz everyone's like oh how
can you not realize is Bruce Wayne you
know Batman or a simple maths they did a
study and it turns out that when you
cover up the eyes in the top part of the
face it messes with your recognition and
to prove it they took a bunch of
celebrities and put their faces and
Batman masks and said you know Photoshop
the men and they're just like we're not
gonna tell you who these people are
because there was like a worker goes oh
it's Michael Keaton well you knew it was
my competing to begin with you know who
the cast is they're like here's
celebrities well-known faces see if you
can recognize them I got two out of ten
well okay no well let Lee put those now
true I confuse Michael Clark Duncan in
ving rhames so I may not be the best as
someone who openly admit I would be
fooled by the Clark Kent Superman thing
like those glasses with Romeo because I
really am you know that oblivious in
that blind hidden I guess Oh number of
people about this test and it's true
most couldn't get most of them the
homeowners was they had Hillary Clinton
in a Batman mask my mom would not have
gotten that at all like it's completely
different looking face no but I say I
think he should have taken the whole
mask off I can't that's a really
nitpicky guy down that didn't bother me
hey what about that charming
conversation with the priest oh yeah
yeah whoopsy and tipsy like love this
guy's and is it a guy came and then
hacked him in front of his family
thank you Father you know it's it's nice
to see more with the priest I it is it's
a great scene I that's like wow like you
do like any just chance for a sliver of
Hope in that conversation just bad whole
story and it's like that was like
something out of Dark Knight it's like
some people just want to watch the land
yeah like it's nice to see the priests
get more because he had again they make
him interesting they pick a good actor
to do it because that's just we've seen
the priest in a superhero movie is like
the psychic or whatever so often again
it's just so easy for them to get boring
so you have to have it's a great way to
have a man
cliched conversation in an interesting
way yeah it kind of makes you forget
it's a cliche comments cuz I mean right
I like it would even the demo father
like the the second he starts going I'm
like oh this is gonna suck like I've
seen this in every other comic book we
were movie with good versus evil like
another way yeah they found a way to
make it really interesting to listen to
and it's acted beautifully shot and
gorgeously no I so very very cool um
doing the real man it's gonna get real
in the next one